Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute nothingness
in the heart of the most holy trinity, to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the purpose of
my existence by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother Mary
and in the divine will of God. And in this same manner may I live, pray, act, eat, walk, sleep,
and do everything. May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants or desires,
and may you my beloved divine will do with me whatever you want or desire.
All I ask is that you bind me to your most holy will so intimately that I may never swear from
carrying out what I know to be your good pleasure, and that I remain so docile to the movements of
your divine will, that you never perceive even a breath of resistance in my soul to your requests
of me. Come divine will with all the angels and saints, especially my sweet mother Mary,
to touch my forehead, to imprint on it the Holy Spirit, and infuse in me true light,
so that I may understand the truths and the good that are in these writings and prayers. Amen.
So let's begin reflecting this evening on May the 3rd 1926. And this is a very important message,
giving us one of the major clues about the living in the divine will, and that one of the
real keys to living in the divine will is that you'll find that the prayer is universal.
If you're still wanting to be absolutely particular, then you need to watch out.
Okay, so we start now several times this evening, Louisa is going to break into prayer, which is
really nice. I was about to fuse myself, Louisa said, in the holy divine volition, according to
my usual way, and I said Supreme Majesty, I come in the name of all now notices universal prayer.
From the first to the last man, we have to understand that every human being created by God
is his family. He wants everyone to be saved and come to the knowledge of the truth. We're told
that several times in the New Testament. So I come in the name of all from the first to the last man
that will exist on the earth. And why are we coming? It is to give you the homage, the adoration,
and the praise. The translation has all that in the plural, which is literalism from the Italian
makes no sense in English. We give you all the homage, the adoration and the praise and the love
that each person owes you. And to make all reparations, that is, reparation for every single soul from
Adam to Zachary. We want to do everything for all. The reparations are for every soul and for
every single sin. Now, when you go into the hours of the Passion, Louisa goes out of her way to
explain in several of the hours of the Passion that Jesus actually makes reparation for every
single sin individually. And so we have to enter into his reparations and make reparation for all
as well. Now, why do we offer the homage and adoration and praise? Well, A, to give God the glory that
is His Jew. And B, to make an act of supreme divine charity so that everybody has the possibility of
being saved no matter what era they have actually lived in. And this is our duty as the true children
of God. So Louisa said, "While I was praying this, Jesus moved in my interior and told me. My daughter,
this way of praying, is only of my will." People who are praying in an ordinary way,
very often they go to God with a laundry list or a shopping list and they want all of these things
from God. The person who is living in the divine will is actually cooperating intimately with Jesus
in His service to God in praise and adoration and homage and His service to every human being
in making reparation and covering for them so that in their name, we actually give God the praise
and the homage that is His Jew. Now, this is a very important thing. None of these people have lived
in the divine will. Many of them have lived in ancient religions or pagan religions or false
religions or no religion. And yet if you simply look at them as people who are sick and needy,
if we have somebody actually physically sick or needy or mentally or emotionally sick and needy,
we will do what is necessary for them to enable them to be able to live as full a life as they can.
That's what we're doing in the divine will for every single soul. It's a most wonderful mission.
It's a very privileged mission. So Jesus said, this way of praying is only of my will because
the divine will alone can say I come in the name of all before the supreme majesty.
So only the divine will operating within us will get us to pray that way. In fact, with its all
seeingness and its immensity, the divine will sees everything and embraces everyone. So it can say
and not just as a manner of speaking, it can say it in reality. I come in the name of all to do
for you all that the creature actually owes you. No human being can say in reality we can
say it as a wish list. We can't say it in reality. I come in the name of all. So this is the sign
that my will reigns in you. That is a very important statement and I would put a VIP on this whole
section if I were you. Here's your discernment as to whether you are being led in this direction
and at this level. Okay. So he said, no human being can say in reality. I come in the name of all.
This is the sign. If you're praying that way, this is the sign that my will is actually
reigning in you. I think that's very, very, very consoling. So while Jesus was saying this,
he continued to pray in a loud voice and Louisa followed him and together they found themselves
before the Supreme Majesty. Now this is following the usual plan of this entire text of 36 volumes
and that is Louisa is given a revelation immediately they put it into practice.
So here they are Jesus and herself before the Supreme Majesty. Oh, how beautiful it was to
pray with Jesus. All things were invested by his words and by his acts. Now notice praying
through him with him and in him that everything becomes invested with not only his words but also
with his actions as well. And since his divine will was everywhere and in each created thing,
one could hear his creative words, his adoration and everything he was doing being repeated
everywhere. That is the extraordinary thing. He is the one who does all this adoration to the
divine majesty and gives all this homage and praise. We enter into him and through him and with him
and in him and in the divine will we follow. So Louisa said, I felt myself becoming smaller.
That's John 3 30. He must grow greater and I must grow smaller. There's another key for you about
living in the divine will. If your ego isn't getting smaller and smaller and God becoming
greater and greater in all your thoughts, all your words and all your actions, watch out.
Because where this living in the divine will goes is that the human ego is put aside and the divine
takes over. It's a wonderful thing. So Louisa said she felt herself getting smaller being in the
presence of Jesus doing this. I was all amazed and he said, but my daughter don't be surprised.
It is my will that by locating while reigning in God reigns in the soul at the same time.
By location means living in two places at the same time. Tri-location is living in three places.
We never hear a tri-location. So by location means that the divine will is reigning in heaven
and the divine will, the same divine will wants to reign in our souls. So quite literally we are
divinized and brought to live at this extraordinary level. So don't be surprised. It is my will that
by locating while reigning in God reigns in the soul at the same time. And with its divine ways,
it prays, it loves, it operates within her. That is what's going on. We read the last day that
in the divine will in our blessed mother, it was the divine will who interceded in a divine way
in her and through her for the coming of the Redeemer. Now the divine will wants to pray and
intercede in us and through us also for the coming of this new era and the triumph of the two hearts
of Jesus and Mary and the new Jerusalem and all that we know about in the book of Revelation.
So it's the divine will that prays in us, loves through us and operates in us. It is fantastic.
So it's impossible for us not to enjoy, not to love and not to listen to our will
by locations in the creature. Now let's take that one slowly. If it truly is the divine will
that's praying in me and through me, then it's not possible for God to deny a prayer that I pray.
It's not actually possible because it's his own divine will that's praying it.
So that's why we were given the discernment at the very beginning that you will know that you
are praying in this divine way when your prayer is universal. Your concern is for the salvation of
every soul past, present and future. When you're concerned about them all, then you're moving at
this level. So if the divine will is praying like that in us and through us, it's not possible for
God to deny the results. So it should be extraordinary results from our prayers and our intercessions.
But God being wisdom itself knows that if we see the fruits of our prayers too quickly,
we become cocky and we become self-reliant and we lose everything. So most of the time he cannot
actually allow us to see the fruits of our prayers. We have to wait until we get to happen.
On the contrary, he said, the divine will alone brings to us as if on its lap our joy,
our happiness and our love which overflowed from our womb in our work at extra, which is the creation
that's the work of God outside of himself. Okay, it repeats the feast for us. It renews in us the joy
we felt in creating so many beautiful things worthy of us. How not to love the one who gives us the
occasion to bylocate our will. He's saying it's not possible for him not to have a very special
love for the person living in the divine will. It's not actually possible because this person
by letting the divine will reign within herself to give us divine love, divine adoration and divine
glory. It's actually not possible for him not to appreciate that. I mean, it's incredible. So in
the next paragraph, he's going to explain that even on a human level, everything is in the will.
If you make up your mind to do something, you'll put all your energy into it. And so he's trying to
get round to us that everything for him is in the divine will, absolutely everything. Therefore,
the living in my will is the Prodigy of Progeses because everything is in the will, both for God
and for human beings. How many things we could do, but because we do not want to do them,
we don't do them. The will is necessary. When we want something, we are all love,
all power, all eyes, hands and feet. In sum, all of our being is centralized in that act,
which our will wants to do. On the other hand, if our will doesn't want to do it, none of our
attributes moves. So this idea that we can twist God's arm to do something we want is completely
wrong. So if our will doesn't want it, none of our attributes moves, it seems to have no life for
anything that our will doesn't want to do. That's why the churches taught us all down the centuries
if it is your will, Lord. I ask this if it is your will. So he continues, our will holds supremacy,
it holds dominion over our being, and it is the ruler of all our attributes. There's no way you
can twist God's arm. This is why the greatest thing that we could give to the creature
was our will, and that in the divine will, we centralized our whole being. So when the divine will
is raining by locating in us, God centralizes his whole being in the divine will. Just think of what
we're saying. It's mind-boggling. We centralized our whole being. Could there be a love more intense,
a miracle more sensational than this, of course, that couldn't. Even more, as much as we can give
to the creature, it seems nothing to us compared to giving her our will. So very often we ask God
for trinkets when he can give us eternity. They can give us everything. So that nothing compares to
our will raining and dominating in her. Now notice the dominating. That means it has control.
It is ruling. In fact, the other things we can give her are the fruits of our works of our
dominations. While when we give her our will, we're giving our very life and our very dominions.
So that's why it keep on reading in these writings that for someone living in the divine will,
what is yours is mine and what is mine is yours. That's why we can say the sun is mine. The galacties
are mine. The trees are mine. The earth is mine. Everything is mine. Including all my brothers and
sisters, the seven billion on planet earth today, they're also mine and I must take them to heaven
with me. What is more value Jesus said, which is of more value, the fruits or the life? Naturally,
it's the life. So we give the fount or source of all goods and one who possesses the fount or the
source of all goods don't need the fruits. In other words, if the greatest thing is given to you,
the lesser is not necessary. He has told us that many times. Even if the person gave us everything
or made the greatest sacrifices, but did not give us her little will in order to let ours rain,
she'd give us nothing. Now that you need to put a VIP beside that or a flag, green light and gold
beside it. You could give God all the gifts you like and if you don't give him your will,
you've given nothing. It's like we experience in human life that if parents give everything to a
child, but don't give them love, they've given nothing. But parents can be the poorest of the poor
and give very rich love to their children. And their children are princes because love is the
greatest of the gifts. So if we don't give our will to the Lord, we have actually given nothing.
Even more, when things are not produced by our will, that means all our acts coming out of his will.
But they're not produced by our will. As great as they may be, we look at them as outside of us.
Not our thing. Things that don't belong to us. Very, very interesting. So in the next paragraph then,
he tells us that the divine will decides to come and buy locate in the little hovel of our souls.
I love the expression. So Louisa reacts to what she has just heard, you see, and she said to the
Lord, is all this possible that the divine will reach is the point of actually by locating in order
to reign in the creature as in its own dwelling, as in the divine womb. You know, that is the same
on earth as it is in heaven. Thy will be done on earth as it is in heaven. Jesus said at my daughter,
do you know how this happens? Not only does it happen, but I'll explain how it happens.
And so he gives an example and he's excellent on the examples. He gives such extraordinarily
simple examples to explain something awfully profound, which of course is the sign of genius.
So he said, this is what happens. Imagine a little and poor hovel in which a king taken by love for
it wants to reside. So the voice of the king can be heard coming out from within that little hovel.
From that little hovel comes his commands as well as his works. Inside of the hovel are foods
apt to nourish the king and the chair worthy of him on which he can sit. So the king has changed
nothing of what befits his royal person. He's only changed his residence. That's brilliant.
He's only changed his residence. So from the royal palace of his will and with the greatest delight
he has chosen the hovel. Think of the cave in Bethlehem for example. For the king of kings and
the lord of lords was born on this earth. He needed nothing of earth, nothing whatever.
The little hovel is the soul. The king is my will. How many times do I not hear the voice of my will
that praise, speaks, teaches and the little hovel of your soul he says to Louisa? How many times do I
not see my works come out of it? And I rule and I vivify or make alive and preserve all created
things from within your hovel because if he is reigning in the soul he's ruling. He's ruling the
earth as well as heaven and he is preserving all of creation. He's doing everything he needs to do
on the earth. It's fascinating. My will does not take account of your littleness. This is terribly
important. There are so many people that because they were wounded in childhood or had difficult
experiences in life, think of themselves as worthless as distinct from being little.
And others may think that because I'm little I'm a nobody and who would care about someone who is
a nobody. So I want to give you Matthew 18 verses 3 to 4 where the lord says he wants all the little
ones together around him because the kingdom of God belongs to them. And the little as he's talking
about is the John 3 30 I mentioned a few minutes ago that in his greatness I become less and less
and less. But I become less and less and less in terms of pride and arrogance and all the stuff
that puffs us up. And I become something beautiful for God. And I become a container that he can
actually come into a little hobble he can reign in. So my will does not take into account your
littleness, nor your incapacity, nor your inability to learn or to do great things or anything else.
That's irrelevant to him. All he wants is the gift of your will and he will do the rest.
On the contrary he says the divine will likes the littleness greatly. Now if you look at all the
history of the saints down through the ages and the people who have been chosen for apparitions
of Jesus and Mary through little people either physically they were children or they were poor
or they were nobodies in the idea of society. There were little people. So what the divine will
looks for is absolute dominion. That is the freedom to reign in us. Because through absolute
dominion it can do everything that the divine will want and place whatever it likes in us and
through us. In other words to use different language it costs not less than everything.
Remember to eat rich born heifer? That quotation has come from him. It costs not less than everything.
But we know ourselves that human beings demand this of us as well. Women who marry for example
have to sacrifice their family name and take on a new name. Just to give you an idea of some of the
sacrifices that we think are perfectly ordinary. Let me give you the last couple of lines in a
sentence again and that is that I am the I am not and he is the I am and so what he wants is that the
I am transformed the I am not so that it becomes a container of the I am. Let me see if I can say
it some other way. If you take a seborium it's just a container and the living Lord the body of blood,
soul and divinity of Jesus Christ is put into it. So we become a container or a receptacle
in which the Lord can reside and he can work and he can do his great miracles. It's a wonderful
thing that we're being told there. Okay so let's go on to May the 6th 1926 and the Lord says that
the children of the divine will are first in the kingdom of heaven. Why are they first? Because
they've allowed him to reign on the earth in and through them. Okay so Louisa said I was fusing
myself in the holy divine volition according to my usual way and I prayed to our celestial mother
and to be with me and to give me her hand so that guided by her I may
requite my God with all the love the adoration and the glory that everyone owes him.
Now one of the very striking things about Louisa's spirituality is her Marian devotion
and when I say the words Marian devotion we can think of all the beautiful prayers people pray
and all the rest of it. Louisa's Marian devotion is very practical. She actually asks blessed mother
to enable her to do in the divine will what she's being asked to do and she enters into our blessed
mother's acts as well. That is an aspect of devotion that we really need to do. So while I was saying
this she said my beloved Jesus moved in my interior which of course is Luke 17 21 and one Corinthian
3 16 the kingdom of God is within you. My daughter he said you must know that the first
before the supreme majesty are those who have lived in my volition and who have never gone
out of it. Now it's the second half that really gets you. We're all trying to live in it but if
to make sure you never actually go out of it and a person can go out of the divine will
if they let a problem for example take over and let the problem dictate and they start giving a
natural reaction to the problem instead of staying in the divine will and letting the divine will
actually do things. So I want to give you Matthew 2023 where we're told that the apostles had a
dispute a dispute as to who was the greatest but in 2023 James and John's mother asked Jesus
if they could be at his right and his left in the kingdom of heaven. The answer to that Jesus
said that those places were only for those to whom the father had allotted them and here you're
being told that the people closest to God are the ones who have lived the divine will. Now if you go
into the book of Revelation and go into chapter 5 and see the structure of the throne room then
the people who are closest to God are around that sea of glass. If you're asking about who has the
primary place on the right and on the left they are the two people that have enabled God to bring
his fiats upon the earth our blessed mother bringing the the Fiat of redemption and Louisa
bringing the Fiat of sanctification. If the apostles had known that 2000 years earlier
they wouldn't have liked it to women but that's how it is because the children of the divine will
are going to be closest to God because they have lived in the divine will and if you die in the
divine will you take God to heaven with you and so the big big big big grace is to pray
that you will die in the divine will make sure you pray that every I pray it every single night
that whatever happens whatever the circumstances that I will actually die in the divine will
because then you have the privilege of taking God from the earth to the heavens
which other souls wouldn't understand at all. So my daughter you must know that the first
before the supreme majesty are those who have lived in my volition and have never gone out of my will
so the number one then is our blessed mother. My mother came to the world after 4000 years
and yet in the eyes of God she became before Adam why because she never went out of the divine will
Adam did. Her acts her love are in the first order of creatures the other way of saying that is
she has primacy or she has first place because she was the closest to God she was bound to him
with the tightest bonds of sanctity union and likeness because of divine will because we're told
back in Genesis 1, 27 and 27 that it was by pouring the divine will into us that we became like God.
By living in our will our blessed mother's acts became inseparable from ours and throughout all
of these volumes we've heard Jesus refer to his mother as my inseparable mother and being inseparable
these acts are the closest as something natural to her creator so she was able to live on this
divine level and her acts were divine will all the time throughout her entire life.
Before and after do not exist in the divine will because everything is in one act everything
is in the first act therefore one who lives in our will even if she came last in time in history
she comes always before everything if she lives in the divine will so there will be generations of
people coming after us living in the new Jerusalem living in the ear of the divine will who will be
greater than us why because they will come into the divine will an awful lot earlier in life
and they will understand it at a much deeper level and they will be able to give God an absolutely
extraordinary gift for many of us we have come into the divine will late in life
so it's only from the time you actually come into the divine will that you can give this service
so there will be people coming after us who will be before us therefore one who lives in our will
even if she comes last comes always before everything so the last will be first
and the first will be last that is people in generations before us who didn't know about the
divine will so it's not the era in which souls come out to the light of time that will be considered
it's whether the life of my will has been in them as the center of life that's the issue
not at what era you lived in and whether the divine will was reigning and dominating in all
of their acts or notice the little word all sometimes one word makes a huge difference
the dominating in all of the acts not just in some of them so the person is living 24 7 3 6 5
in the divine will so our will is reigning and dominating in all of their acts just as it rains
and dominates in the womb of the blessed Trinity these will be the first their acts done in our will
will rise above all the acts of all other creatures naturally enough because most of them are doing
only human acts and therefore these souls will be our crown we would sort of say in English our
crowning glory so as you are calling my mother in my will not just calling her to give me a return
of love and adoration and of glory my will united to the two of you together you ask her blessed
the lady to do it with you and the divine will combines the two and the love and the glory and
the adoration in which the sovereign queen did have become your acts because you've united yourself
with her and yours have become hers in heaven everybody owned everything my will placed everything
in common the one has become inseparable from the other and i heard in you the voice of my mother
i think that's absolutely absolutely brilliant i heard in you the voice of my mother i think
incredible i heard her love i heard her adoration and i heard her glory and in my mother i heard your
voice that's even more incredible that coming out of the blessed mother would be my little miserable
act it's even more incredible and in my mother i heard your voice i heard you loving me adoring me
and glorifying me so you see how desperately important it is for us to join ourselves with
our blessed mother how happy i felt in finding and hearing the mother in the daughter and the daughter
in the mother my will unites everyone notice that my will unites everyone and everything you'll notice
that while we come from different countries and different cultures different languages
and different time zones that if we're in the divine will we're all one we just discovered we are one
it would not be true living in my will nor a work of my mind if it did not centralize everything that
belongs to it and all of its eternal works in the soul who lives in it in whom it has its kingdom
and dominion therefore when we are living in the divine will he centralizes all in us
it's totally amazing if it were not so the kingdom of my will would be a divided kingdom
which cannot be because my will unites all its works together and makes them all one single act
because the divine will is one single act and even though it is said that it creates and it redeems
and it identifies and so on these are all the effects of this one single act in other words
god wanted to do this and so these are the effects and we have to look at the effects
piece by piece because we couldn't handle it otherwise these are the effects of that single act
which never changes its action therefore the origin of one who lives in my will is eternal
she's inseparable from her creator and from all those in my will in whom my will has its
kingdom and its dominion that means that the life in us is the same as the life in the saints in
heaven we are one with them and we're one with each other so we have union with god and with
each other which is the fulfillment of the command of Jesus in john 1334 that were to love
as he loved and it's the fulfillment of the command in Matthew 22 verses 35 to 40 that the
greatest commandment of god is to love and love as you know unifies it's really really marvelous
so let's come to me the 10th 1926 and so Jesus is going to change the message a bit here and he's
going to talk about living in the darkness of the human will is a nightmare of darkness and they
were brought out into the light of living in the divine will because god is light so to dispel the
nightmare of darkness we have to be invested with the light now in many many many messages up to now
we've heard louisa say that through a light that came to her something happens or she understands
or she says she's invested with this light or she discovers herself in this incredible light and
she discovers it is endless okay so she says my poor mind was swimming in the immensity of the
eternal volition and my sweet Jesus transported me outside of myself in the act in which the sun
was rising what enchantment to see the earth the plants the flowers the seas everything undergoing
such an amazing transformation all of them freed themselves now what what's the language now all
of them freed themselves from a nightmare that oppressed them all rose to new life which the light
gave them and acquired their beauty and development which the light and the heat gave them in order
to make them grow so the meditation that louisa is doing is that we come out of the nightmare
of the darkness of the night and open up and develop and grow in the brightness of the sunlight
the light seemed to take them by the hand in investing them giving fecundity to plants and
color to flowers to dispel the shadows of darkness from the sea and give it its silvery shades with
its light but who could see all the effects of the solar light produced by investing all the
earth covering everything with the garment of light it would be too long if i went on to describe
everything so i want to give you sam 19 verses 5 and 6 that while the creation is mute it actually
declares the glory of god from one end of life and history to the other so in the second paragraph
then we're going to look at the light being life now this is very johanna and and you need the
the prologue of john because john says that jesus is the light of life okay so that's john chapter
one verses one to seven all together it's the prologue now when i was seeing this my beloved jesus
told me my daughter how beautiful is the rising of the sun how it changes all of nature now jesus
is picking up louisa's meditation and he's going to take it further and by transforming nature
into its very light it gives to each thing the effects needed to make them produce the good they
contain but in order to do this the light must actually invest down and this is what he's getting
at that we have to open up to let the light actually invest us to let the light actually
touch us as the light touches the plants and we've got to let the light mold us as it molds the plants
and we've got to let the light penetrate deep into us just as it penetrates deep into them
giving them sips of light and God wants to give us sips of the divine will at every nanosecond
of your being but you need to ask him you need to tell him you want it and don't just say it once
so and this must happen in order to infuse life with the good that they must produce
this has been given to us very detailed word by word and if you write this out on a piece of paper
you will have the answer to the question that many people ask how do I do this how do I actually
get into the divine will and so the illustration here is just absolutely marvelous and because it's
going from nature and it's going from what the sun does to the plants people automatically have
a context in which to absorb how this applies to us so let's go back and look at this again
in order for the transformation to take place the light must actually invest the plants
it must touch them it must mold them now molding means a complete renewal it must penetrate so deep
we call all this photosynthesis in science it must penetrate so deep into them as to give them sips
of light in order to infuse them with the good that they must produce so they have to produce from
buds they have to produce plants and flowers and fruits and all the rest of it and so if the plants
the flowers the sea did not let themselves be invested by the light the light would be as though
dead to them and they would remain in the nightmare of darkness now this is all for us
we will remain in the nightmare of the darkness of the human will if we don't open up and ask God
to invest us with his light and so this nightmare of darkness would serve as a tomb to bury them in
other words you'd never see you'd never come out to a higher life we have so many people living
around us who are walking in this darkness and they don't even know it's so sad so here we have
the word virtue coming up and it's used not in the way that we use it in English so it's going to be
used twice in the next sentence so I've used two different words for it to try and make the sentence
more meaningful the work of darkness is to give death but the power of light is to give light
so I've tried two different words to try and bring the whole sentence out and of course this is John
chapter 1 verses 4 to 5 that the darkness could not overpower the light but the darkness would try
and the whole of the gospel is light and darkness in contention the whole of the passion of Jesus is
light and darkness and contention the resurrection of Jesus is the light has won the darkness couldn't
overcome it you know you can interpret the whole thing in terms of light and darkness is fascinating
so if it wasn't for the light of the song on which all created things are dependent and from
which all of them receive life nothing good would be on the earth on the contrary it would be a
frightening and horrible thing to look at therefore the life on the earth is bound to the light now
you know where we're going with this in the next paragraph because he's going to lift this up now
onto the level of divine will so my daughter the son is the symbol of my will so you have seen how
beautiful and enchanting is it's rising over the earth you've seen how many effects it produces
how many different colors what many beauties and how many transformations the light can produce
and how this light has been placed there by its creator in order to give life this is a wonderful
botanical lesson here in order to give life in order to give gross now he's going to go on and
tell us that the divine will wants to give us divine life and gross in the divine will so here's
another key for you if you truly are living in the divine will you will actually notice that there
is growth going on and you will also notice that interior beauty is enhanced more and more as the
divine order is brought into our being so if this is what the sun does in order to fulfill its office
given to it by god much more does the son of my will which was given to man to infuse in him
the life of the creator there's your genesis one 27 again and genesis two seven oh how much more
enchanting and beautiful is the rising of the son of my will over the creature dispelling the darkness
of the human will by pounding on her i love the word he doesn't get in by coming as a gentle little
breeze he had to not pull off his horse by pounding on her it's like transforms her and gives her the
different colors of the beauty of her creator the different colors now are the aspects of the
different attributes of god by investing her by molding her melt me mold me fill me use me
think of Jeremiah 18 and the molding of the clay and the potter okay it must mold her and it must
penetrate into her that means into your every fiber of your being into your soul into your spirit
and most particularly into your will it must penetrate into her and give her sips of divine life
that she may grow and produce the effects of the goods with the life of her creator contains so
if this is happening to us and the divine will is investing us and molding us and penetrating into
us and giving us sips of divine life of course there will be effects because as a human being
you will grow your soul will develop everything will change improve and you become a glowing presence
so it penetrates into her and gives her sips of the divine life that she may grow and produce
the effects of the goods with the creator contains so it is that we become more and more god like
or like him who created us now what would happen to the earth without the sun
and he has just told us at the end of the last paragraph that it would be horrific so here he
says much more ugly and frightening would the soul be without my will now this is a stimulus for us
to intercede for people because Jesus tells us that as the soul embedded in its own will is
embedded in darkness and he says it's frightening for him to look at and we know from Hebrews 1214
that nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of god so how she decays from her origin
now we have enough evidence of just watching news on television to see how human beings can decay
into literal beasts how the nightmare of passions and vices more than darkness makes her die spiritually
now the church calls that mortal sin and prepares the tomb in which to bury her but you have seen
that the light of the sun can do good in so far as the plants and the flowers and the other things
allow themselves to be touched and invested by the light remaining with their mouths open in
order to receive the sips of life which the sun gives to them so in other words it depends on us
god is willing to give us everything we may not be willing to receive okay so we have to be open
to god all the time and so Jesus says that if we don't remain with our mouths open to receive the
sips of the divine will he can't give them to us that is how it is with my will he said it can do
so much good it can infuse so much beauty and divine life but only in so far as the soul allows
herself to be touched invested molded by the hands that we've heard this about four times already
this is amazing so he's saying it depends on us it depends on us i mean we have the ocean out
there you may or may not ever go out swimming it depends on you we have beautiful places to walk
but you may not decide to go walking it depends on you the sun may be shining but you may decide
you're not going out it depends on you so everything happens in so far as the soul let yourself be
touched invested molded by the hands of the light of my will if the soul gives herself prey to this
light abandoning herself completely in it the supreme will will perform the greatest
tragedy of creation which is the divine life in the creature so in the next paragraph he tells us
we need sips of this divine life at every instant oh if the sun could form with the reflection of
its light as many suns on each plant in the seas and in the mountains in the valleys what more
beautiful enchantment what beauty more radiant how many more tragedies would there not be
in nature that is if the sun was capable of doing that yet what the sun up at the sky does not do
my will does do in the soul who lives in it and whoever remains with our mouth open like a little
flower in order to receive the sips of light which my will gives her to form the life of the divine
will within her he'll give it at every instant therefore be attentive take in every instant he says
it himself sips of divine life and sips of the light of my will that it may accomplish in you the
greatest of tragedies that is that you may have divine life in the creature now notice he finished
this paragraph the same as the last one but this time what he said was you have to be open you have
to be willing okay so in the next paragraph louisa makes a prayer to the lord in response to this
and we see the result of it after this louisa said i was saying to my highest and only good my
love i unite my intelligence to yours so that my thoughts may have life in yours and she's showing
us how to pray and diffusing in your will my thoughts may flow in each thought of the creature
and rising together before the celestial father we will bring him the homage and the
subjection and the love of each thought of the creature and we will pray that all created intelligence
may be reordered and harmonized in their created some very beautiful prayer and i want to do the
same with the gazes of jesus with his words and with his works and with his steps and with every
heartbeat if you're able for that amount of words to be wonderful i felt all transformed in jesus
she said in such a way that i found myself as though in act in everything my jesus had done this
is the result everything that he had done everything he was doing to restore the glory of the father
and in the good that he had prayed for for creatures his work was one with mine now you heard earlier
that the acts of our blessed mother were made one with louis's when she united with our blessed mother
and here when she unites with jesus his acts are hers as well this is the glory of praying in the
divine will so his work was one with mine the love the will was all one and my sweet jesus added my
daughter how beautiful is the prayer the love the work of the soul in my will
he admires it her acts are filled with the whole of divine fullness now please underline that
her acts are filled with the whole not part of the divine fullness their fullness is such that
they embrace everything and everyone even god himself for all eternity your thoughts will be seen
in mine your eyes your words in mine your works and your steps in mine and your heartbeat
palpitating in mine it will go on forever because anything in the divine will goes on forever
so the more we do in the divine will the better
and the reason is that the will that gives us life is one the love that moves us is the same
and it pushes us and it binds us and what makes us it's it's all one it's a very difficult sentence
there very difficult to make it English the will that gives us life is the same the love that moves
us is the same and it pushes us and it binds us in an inseparable way is one i want to give you a
couple of scriptures for that i haven't got time to go into them one thessalonians five five
Colossians one twelve one Peter two nine and Ephesians five eight
well flagged in scripture do we as it continues this is why the son of my will surpasses
to an infinite degree and in a more surprising way the son present in the atmosphere naturally
because one is divine see the great difference the son created by god while pounding on the
earth invests it and produces admirable and innumerable effects but it does not depart from its source
it descends down below it rises up high it touches the stars but the fullness of light remains always
within its own sphere now we've been told this many times otherwise it would not be able to
invest everything with a slight always equally but in spite of all this the solar light does not
penetrate into the heavens and does not invest a throne of god because it's only a planet
it's not able to penetrate into god himself and make its light one with the inaccessible light
one Timothy six 15 to 16 god lives in inaccessible light it's not able to make itself one with the
inaccessible light of the supreme being nor can it invest the angels and the saints or the celestial
mother by giving us the negative he now able to give us the positive because those of us who have
free will and can enter into divine will you can do all this on the other hand so here's the positive
side when the son of my will reigns in the soul with all its fullness its light does penetrate
everywhere it penetrates into the hearts and into the minds of those who live on the earth
but what surprises is that it rises up high it invests the whole of creation and brings the
kiss of the light of the supreme will to the son itself it brings it to the stars and to the heavens
the divine will which reigns in creation and the son of the divine will which reigns in the soul
meet they kiss each other that means they unite they love each other and they make each other happy
so you talk about union there becoming one and while remaining in the creation because the son
of my will leaves nothing behind but brings everything with itself it penetrates into the heavens it
invests everyone the angels the saints the sovereign queen it gives its kiss to all it gives new joys
new contentment and you love but that's not all the divine will by locates is in the creature kisses
loves adores the will reigning in heaven itself you need to give that a big big marker in your own book
the divine will reigning a by locates in the creature kisses loves adores the will reigning in god
himself it brings everyone and everything to him and as they dive into each other it rises again to
follow its course in fact since the fullness of the son of the eternal will is in the soul no
is the fullness because god doesn't come by half he does nothing by half this fullness is at her
disposal and as she emits her acts loving praying repairing etc the son of the divine will continues
its course to give all souls the surprise of its light its love and its life so we're literally
giving life to all souls past present and future that fills me with delight so while this son of
the eternal will rises and follows its course to perform its setting in the womb of the divinity
another one rises to follow in its way enveloping everything even the celestial father hand so you
have it's like wave upon wave upon wave it never ceases to then have its golden sunset in the
womb of the supreme majesty so the by locations of my will are innumerable because it's every second
if we allow the lord to operate every second in us this son rises at each act of the creature done
within the son of the supreme volition which does not happen with the son present in the atmosphere
of course because it's only a planet it's always the same it can't multiply but if the son had the
power of making as many sons rise for as many times as it did its course over the earth how many sons
would you not see up in the sky what enchantment how many more goods the earth would receive therefore
how many goods does the soul who lives completely completely is a hundred percent
in my will now this what he's looking for is that he can dominate now it only reign but dominate in
us so therefore it has to be the hundred percent therefore how many goods does the soul who lives
completely in my will not do by giving her god the occasion to buy locate his will and to let him
repeat the prejudice that only a god can do having said this he disappeared isn't that very rich
thank you for joining us god bless